would you rather date a girl that has
let's say 75 bodies
or a child
but how much buddies does the girl of
the child have uh let's say let's say
low five
three three two and two
probably the girl with the child but
it's still awkward at the same time but
yeah
okay okay wait do I know any of these 75
buddies
um let's say
yeah at 75 you got to know one you gotta
know one
75 buddies mom 75 bodies over a child
yeah every time
definitely the child because today the
amount girls demand from boys they often
get boys to work hard like anything and
they hardly even give a child and they
part up very quickly if boys don't work
hard and earn an amount
so so you would date the woman with the
child over 75. yeah and today many times
that the basic benefit for a boy to
marry a girl is just pushing on
generation
there's hardly any other benefit of
marriage today there isn't that's why
pain people get married if you look at
our generation for me I'd say I would
choose the girl with a child because
the woman who's got 75 bodies is less
valuable it's like I don't want her
because now everybody wants her or
everybody's had hers yeah but you can
put her to the side yeah but really
reality someone has got a child is
actually less valuable because they've
already given the highest honor they can
give to a man by pushing out someone
else's child so you might see it
different because you've got a child but
so a man like me like there's no I get
no benefit from coming in and bringing
up another man's child another man's
there's there's no benefit for me at all
I can't pass on my seeds like that it's
not my so have you ever dated a girl
that's got a child before it doesn't
sound like you have no but uh no I've
I've slept with my children don't know
that's not the question I asked have you
ever dated a girl that's got a child no
but I wouldn't why because men don't men
don't finish up immense games
the truth of the matter like end of the
day you're gonna see something
differently because you've got a child
but myself I've got to a good age and
I'm with no children my friend over
there as well got a good age or no
children there's some responsibility you
need to have so I think ever when we
grew up we were told that you know if
you went out there we had a child out of
wedlock would be a lot harder for you um
so we knew that but there seems to be
something now they're trying to push
being a stepdad is some type of good
thing that men should do and it's honor
it's not an honor it's a big disrespect
for us because we get continuous
reminder that we were not the first
choice that as far as I'm concerned both
of you women are virgins the only way I
know you're not a virgin is when you
come with a child and that's how the
world looks at it so there's no benefits
for us man
why do you feel that it's so good
otherwise how do we progress Our
Generation
no that's not much I've married the guy
before she should have married like
she's saying he wants to have a kid with
a girl he doesn't want to raise someone
else's kid
he comes down to poor decision making
again as well you know and I think a lot
of you know what you know what really
annoys me I'll tell you what annoys me
is meeting women outside the nightclub
with newly born kids on like one year
old and they're looking for a new man I
just do not understand it you you you
pushed out a whole man's kid that you
have no idea that you that you don't
want to be with now you're outside
looking for a new man and you really
think like you're going to get a good
quality man no you're just gonna get
dates and get your bat blown out so I'm
saying to you that's all you're gonna
get because Society has lied to you made
you think that you can go and get high
and typically you don't get higher than
your baby dad so whatever your baby dad
is when women are cussing their baby dad
we look at you and say oh but you bred
from that man like and now you're trying
to come to me and you want me to come
and pick up the mess so for example let
me say something to you if I meet you
and you've got one child
if I want to
um get married to a woman movie I want
to get a place for us
um if we started a one bedroom might
have been enough because the start even
a two-bedroom cool but I have to think
about your child so when I want to have
my own child we need to actually have a
three bedroom it's already costing me so
if I want to send my children to school
you know I want to sell my truck my
child to private school can I send my
child to private school and send your
kid to the local comprehensive will you
like that if if I want to buy my child
for his for example Jordans but you'll
try to watch trainers I'm like no I'm
gonna buy them high tech is that okay
with you if we go out if we go out for
example to to the fun fair to Thorpe
Park Alton Towers
um my child wants to get ice cream wants
to get some you know wants to get some
teddies and I buy them and then your
child says to me can I have someone said
no go and call your dad and pay for him
are you going to be okay with that the
fact remains is these charts are going
to be a cost for us women don't look it
like that but men we see it like that so
there's no benefits of of me raising
your child other than the ones that you
will see fit can I discipline your child
the way I want to can I hit your child
if I want to you might not see hitting
your child but I may want to do that can
I do that in the future if you have a
female daughter in the future she gets
old enough and she makes an accusation
against me are you going to treat me
like a father or are you going to treat
me as someone these are all things that
men mitigate and think to and because
you don't think as far as head you don't
realize why it's so dangerous and it's
and it's and it's not worth us being
stepdads
boom
what do you guys think of that
the truth
I'm sorry you too you seem shocked I
don't know
or does that make sense to you I don't
know how to feel simply because
I have a stepdad which is her dad yeah
my dad raised her from the age so if I
didn't get a father figure in life I
might have not understood the way that I
think to this day and wasn't necessarily
have to mean me being in relationship
but like maybe just simple things in
life or like how I can look at life or
like my beliefs in Life or like how to
be open-minded who I am as a black woman
if I didn't get those certain things
could I just
hope that my mom was gonna give me all
of that and also odd dad treats us the
same yeah he doesn't differentiate if if
I get she gets if she gets I get well I
think that's also representative of your
mother so your mom's recognize this
man's gonna be a stepdad and she's going
to treat him like probably like we have
different different moms okay wait so
yeah complicated our younger siblings
have so I am the same dad as our younger
siblings and she has to say mum just a
different Dad I'm the only one with a
different dad and I'm the only one with
a different one
so they both brought a kid into the
relationship yeah okay cool I understand
I understand
um yeah but I'll still say the same
thing I think
before men was respected for being
stepdads like they were respected they
were seen as they were picking up
another man there was literally women
would be like oh my God I can't believe
I'm getting married these guys come but
now it's like yo they want they think
being a single mother is like empowering
and it's something to be proud of I'm
like girl like you can't even keep the
man that you bred from like we don't
respect that over here and when we say
it loud it sounds like it sounds mad
because men don't say this because
they're not gonna stay around long
enough they're just gonna hit it and
keep it moving I think there's also
correlation between that and uh um
promiscuous behavior of women as well
because you know we were talking about
hoes before when you sleep around
indiscriminately and you're not really
trying to filter out who you got a
connection with who you see something
long time with that's when you're more
likely to end up being a single mum
because you're having sex with a guy
that probably you've got no future with
and then you just end up with this kid
so I think there's a lot of that going
on as well how these women end up single
moms well and and the problem is it's a
lot bigger liability nowadays to become
a stepfather because one like if she
leaves you have no rights to that child
so you could raise a kid for 10 years
and you could never see that child again
and then on top of that like if you get
married to her and you get divorced like
she can take half
and put and put and put you on child
support if you have more kids
I mean and women and women leave 70 to
80 percent of the time 90 of their
college educated oh no
yeah we're the ones a lot of times women
are afraid of being left but we're the
ones leaving
[Music]
does that surprise you not really no no
do you think that's normal with like
what you've seen yeah definitely
from what my I've seen in my lifetime I
feel like um
like my mom was with
our dad for a while and then she ended
up doing the independent thing and like
doing it herself but I don't know I just
think like they
they understood each other but they were
two different people at the same time of
what they wanted to achieve out of life
did she get remarried no my mom was
never married actually do you do you
think she was happier when she was in a
relationship or out of it
in it you know I don't think she would
have wanted to admit that but yeah yeah
she had happy times when she was single
too but I think just being a family as a
whole would just make any woman or any
couple happy
um where um does that like
do you feel like having that model
growing up like was it
did it help you with men or no no
um
I respect him I love him as a father
figure definitely but there's always
going to be that I'm not really chosen
kind of feeling because he's not really
my biological dad and it's not nothing
against him it's just how I feel
um maybe a lot of people or kids when
they're in mixed or Blended families
probably feel that way too but
I mean it's not therefore they do the
best that they can how I feel is just
how I feel based on
how I would like my family to be I guess
like I would love my dad to still be in
the picture but that's not necessarily
the case
um
I know who my dad is but we don't have a
relationship at all
do you feel like having your dad in the
picture would have helped you like vet
guys better I don't know because now I
know who my dad is I don't think he
would have really made a difference
just being honest you know what what I
get from this is just even listening to
you and I and I feel for you in a way
but I feel for your stepdad because just
listen like imagine a step dad hears
this no he stepped in he's done as best
he can he does all of these things but
yet you still just feel like for some
reason that I just don't belong even
though he's trying to make you belong
obviously he's obviously I feel like
nobody would understand unless they're
in that City no no no but I no I hate I
hate you I'm just saying like it it
probably would hurt him and it's nothing
new that I haven't not said to him
before but once again when I talk about
not wanting to be a stepdad just look at
what you just gave me you gave me I can
bring you up I can come in I can do all
these things but you're still not going
to see me as your dad but I don't know
if it would have made a difference if I
had a relationship with my dad too if
that makes any sense yeah I hear that
but now we don't know about that but the
one the one thing we do know you didn't
but you still have a feeling of this is
not an incomplete feeling yeah and this
is why I say it's important for us to
affect the relationships and we stay and
keep our families together because one
of the biggest things that I've seen is
that my mom and dad have been together
through freaking Finn and it's been the
basis of how I see my life and
relationships and when women don't
prescribe to that I automatically know
this is not someone I want to be with
because of what I've been brought up to
well let me not make it seem like that
no because no because I do want to make
sure that we're showing appreciation for
somebody that actually did make a
difference in my life because if he
wasn't in my life I don't know who I
would actually be today I'm not gonna
make it seem like that because the
conversations that I've had the things
that he's taught me the books that he's
told me to read me making music and
wanting to do more about my Artistry
that was down to him but the inside
feeling I don't know how to explain it
it's an incomplete feeling of knowing
that my dad didn't want my I didn't want
nothing to do with me but one of the
things that I think is important to that
is that people always talk about how
easy it is to go get another man to just
step in like but they don't speak to the
children that have stepped that have
actually grown up in these things where
they never had their dad or and a lot of
times I've spoken to a lot of my friends
and I see it all the all the hurt and
all the trauma that that's been caused
from just women saying oh yeah pick a
next man or your dad can't be in there
like people need to there's something
about identity and the reason I have
such a strong sense of identity is
because I have my history and my roots
back through my Village I go back I know
my grandfather I know all the history
back through the walls and that puts you
a sense of identity and so when you step
into the world and then you meet all
these people that just have all these
broken ideas of how things should be
it's it look it makes it sound like
you're some anomaly or some crazy person
but you're actually not and no I'm not
but I think it's also as much as we all
want things to be a type of way and that
goes with culture as well as religion
I'm not gonna try and act like my life
was a complete blow over because I had a
stepfather in my life and I didn't have
my dad in my life like I'm still
grateful for everything that I've got
because I'm still here I could have
drank the like I could have done a lot
ages ago but that's not the case I feel
like it is still a normality when it
comes to Blended families I feel like if
like it might not necessarily have to be
a dad it could be a woman as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible